welcome to this video this is dennie man
10 wow it's a new opponent we keep
cropping up I still have not fixed this
issue with the flag somehow I mean not
that I'm a huge patriot or anything but
it's kind of weird don't have the flag
there okay 97 that's an uncommon way to
play in the Queens gambit accepted okay
just going to develop yeah this is quite
funny this this position looks like I
just have an extra temple here over the
the Marin variation with Bishop d3 and
then black takes and it's just an extra
tempo good to have good to have but it's
nothing decisive yet of course still a
nice nice for white disposition mmm Oh
came so I'm just going to go yeah 93 he
might play be five I wonder if I should
just try to shut down the b5 possibility
just with a form yeah why not okay he
might might go for e5 here i'm also
going to shut that down and 93 i don't
like him to trade down but ok it would
strengthen my Center a bit so not a big
deal we don't want to trade necessarily
okay so I've definitely like to see a
knight come me too 26 so let's get going
here okay so okay I won't live hmm yeah
it's interesting might be six is
interesting b3 is also an option just
playing yeah let's do that it's kind of
uncut an unusual to wait to play but
it's not looking bad he cannot take
really okay
so is he managed to wow he managed to
get rid of this weakness there on our me
know on this cramping pawn on d5 but in
the process here some killed his pawn
structure there Jeff e6 is very very
weak and the e5 square which is so even
even more an issue okay
so Queen h6 or not that should be should
be a decent square down okay this seems
to be high if I go back to the three
days bishop a six and but i still have
95 them 95 bishop f1 knight c6 ok maybe
queen juicer queen GM g seven hmm
interesting night if I was definitely a
move them giving up the exchange it's
not necessary really I wonder ever
should take the other one actually yeah
well he will take on d3 anyway I guess
no he won't
hmm ok well i don't mind mind that much
anyway those nights are just much
stronger than any rook so take one of
the rooks please yep ok ok so he wants
to play a five day I am with a discover
the check on my queen yeah the issue is
that's all nice and good for white but
how am I actually going to get something
very serious night h5 is so serious idea
map back rank is an issue but okay I
have to have to play at some point
now look the eight was a bit more more a
problem I thought okay night h5 he might
have root if age
yeah yes ruka video and it's somehow
holding time warning
not just six eyes and move to force a
drawn but I don't want to do that just
yet and now I really miss played that
this is a the position was some very
very questionable for black and I should
have really got more than this him
okay a method now is rookie 3g three so
authority has to as to maybe what really
okay that's no big threat rookie 3g
three that's hard to believe f forces is
argument there ok you can check with the
rook you can take i can take this right
route g3 is still a big threat even with
the night coming back from age five yeah
sure let's still rocky three
ok
Jack didn't play that well haven't you
say that really he got far more than
then was necessary check
black resins sure now that didn't play
that well at all I mean around here or
even before that around here why does
some strategically speaking a very much
better very much better especially after
a fire which is very cooperative maybe
Bishop g5 is not good i don't know when
i get kept something but it felt like I
should have more I hit Bishop d3 you are
stronger hmm yeah after this he could
have taken efore which would have been
awkward something like that is not what
I wanted maybe still not bad but it's
not not ideal yeah this should be quite
nice actually be six went back I don't
know maybe I can immediately sacrifice I
don't know I already don't yeah I think
this is a this is interesting okay he
took you there I'm not sure how much
this how much this is really we asked
Queen g7 him I i am ok that sets that
sets a mistake that on my part if he
does that I have nothing the problem is
that he threatening Queenie 5 yeah with
the back ring made so I cannot I cannot
move the Queen mm okay that's bad then
and I have to start with this move jump
comps s equal so I have compensation but
human Queen g7 he missed so now i'm
going there and now it gets kind of
serious here i can draw with 96 of
course but i wanted to find a little bit
at least this is a perpetual rookie 1s i
thought it's drawing hand and computer
agrees computer says like to take
and then wow what wow that's remarkable
the comp gives g4s winning for white why
is this a winner for because of G 59 f
six maybe they are taking root leaf is
kind of kind of a problem hmm Wow this
means that he has to do this move ok
very tricky ok I would never ever play G
for you if he takes that I think I take
the draw I don't really see what else to
do yeah this is a strange move it just
completely ignores what's happening in
the game I don't be a bishop c8 is a non
movement there's nothing but here he is
toast simply g3 check is so too too much
check the IDS he's going to lose the
rest of his pieces there was a somewhat
strange way to defend at the end ok well
thanks for watching